The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR WILLIAMS: OK,
so today's lecture--
we're going to be talking about
probabilistic planning later,
and in these cases
where you're planning
a large state spaces
is very difficult.
You do the MVP planning.
It could be stress that
activity planning, or the likes.
But you have to be
able to figure out
how to deal with
these state spaces.
So Monte Carlo tree searches
is one of the techniques
that people can identify,
over last five years,
is having an amazing performance
improvement over other kinds
of sample-based approaches.
So entity is very interesting
from that standpoint.
And then if we [? link it to ?]
the last lecture,
then the combination
of something,
we just learn about [INAUDIBLE]
and combine it with search,
is very powerful, in this case,
through the state-of-the-art
techniques for that, as much as
tree search [INAUDIBLE] later
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 2: Good
morning, everyone.
As Professor Williams
just said, we
are going to be talking about
Monte Carlo tree search today.
My name is Eann
and I'll be leading
the introduction and motivation
of this presentation.
By the end of this
presentation, you
will know not only why we
care about Monte Carlo tree
searches.
As Professor Williams said,
there's so many algorithms
out there.
Why do we care about
this specific one?
And second, we'll be
going through the pros
and cons of MCTS, as well
as the algorithm itself.
And then lastly, we will
have a pretty cool demo
on how it's applied to Super
Mario Brothers and the latest
Alpha Go AI that built
the second best leading Go
player in the world.
So the outline for
today's presentation
is, first, we're going to talk
about pre-MCTS algorithms.
There are other algorithms
that currently exist out there,
and just a few of them to lead
into why we do care about MCTS
and why these other
algorithms fail.
And second, we'll talk about
Monte Carlo tree searches
itself with Yo.
And lastly, Nick will tell you
more about the applications
of Monte Carlo tree searches.
So the motivation of
these kind of algorithms
is we want to be
able to play games
and we want to be able to create
programs to play these games,
but we want to play
them optimally.
We want to be able
to win, but we also
want to be able do this in
a reasonable amount of time.
So these three can
train itself leads
to different kinds
of algorithms,
and different algorithms
with different complexities
and time, or times to search.
And so that's why
today we're going
to be talking about Monte
Carlo tree searches.
And you'll figure out in a
few slides why we do care.
So these are the types
of games we have.
You have this
chart where there's
fully observable games,
partially observable games,
determinstic, and
games of chance.
And so today, the games
that we care about
are the games that are fully
observable and deterministic.
And these games are games like
chess and checkers and Go.
And we'll also be talking
about another example
with Tic-tac-toe.
So these pre-MCTS
algorithms include
deterministic, fully observable
games, like we said earlier.
And the idea of this, and the
nice thing about these games,
is that they have
perfect information,
and that you have
all of the states
that you need and there's
no opportunity for chance.
And so the idea is
that we can construct
a tree that contains
all possible outcomes
because everything
is fully determined.
And so one of these
algorithms, to address this,
is the algorithm Minimax, which
you might have heard before.
And the idea of
Minimax to minimize
the maximum possible loss.
That sounds a little
weird in the beginning,
but if you take a
look at this tree,
this red dot, for
example, is the computer.
And so in the computer's eyes,
it wants to beat its opponent.
And we're assuming the
opponent wants to win also,
so they're playing
their best game as well.
And so the computer wants to
maximize his or her points,
but also knowing that the
opponent, or the human,
wants to maximize
their own win as well.
And so in the
computer's eyes, it
wants to minimize the
maximum possible lost.
Does that make
sense to everyone?
Yes?
OK.
And so in the
example of Minimax,
we're going to start
with a connect,
or a Tic-tac-toe board,
where the computer is
this board right here, and
the blue Tic-tac-toe boards
are the states that the
computer finally chooses.
It's anticipating the
moves a human could play.
So if you take a
look up here, here's
the current state of the board.
The current state of the board.
And the possible options for the
human are this guy, this guy.
Nope.
Possible options
for the computer,
we have three different options.
And so you'll notice that this
is clearly the obvious winner.
But in the state
of Minimax, it goes
through the entire
tree, which is
different from
depth-first search.
It goes through the entire
tree until it finds the winning
move and the minimize of
the maximum possible points
it could win.
So is there a way we
can make this better?
Yes.
I'm sure you've
heard about pruning,
where, in our human
intuition, it makes sense.
Well, why don't we
just stop when we win,
or when we know
we're going to have
a game that allows us to win?
And so this idea is the
idea of simple pruning.
And so when we combine Minimax
and simple pruning, we have--
anyone know?
AUDIENCE: Alpha, beta.
PROFESSOR 3: Yes.
Our 6.034 head TA
knows about this.
We have alpha-beta pruning,
where we prune away any
branches that cannot
influence the final decision.
So in other words, you wouldn't
keep exploring the tree
if you already knew that
a previous term would
allow you to win.
And so this idea in
alpha-beta pruning,
we have an alpha and a beta.
And so the details
aren't important
for you to know right
now, but the idea
is that we stop whenever
we know we don't
need to go on any further.
So in the games that
have Tic-tac-toe
and Connect 4 and chess,
we have relatively low
branching factor.
So in the case of
Tic-tac-toe, we have 2
to the fourth branching factor.
But what if we have really
large branching factors,
like Alpha Go?
In Alpha Go, we
have 2 to the 250.
Do you see that Mini Max,
or even alpha-beta pruning,
would be an optimal
algorithm for this?
The answer is?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR 3: No.
And this leads us
to out next section.
Our goal is going to talk about
how we can use the Monte Carlo
tree search algorithm for
games with really high
branching factors, and using
the random extension to allow us
to see, ultimately, how Alpha
Go, which is Google's AI,
was able to beat the leading
Go player in the world.
PROFESSOR 3: All right, guys.
So this is the part
where we re-explain
the algorithm itself.
And before we dive
into this, I want
to make something
really clear, which
is that because these
are technical details
and because we actually
want you to understand them,
and because I definitely didn't
understand this the first three
times I read the paper.
I really want you to feel
free to ask any questions
on your mind, with the knowledge
that, in my experience,
it is very rare that someone
asks a question in class that's
[INAUDIBLE] OK, so really,
whenever you have one.
OK.
So why are we doing this?
Well, the ideal
goal behind MTCS is
that we want to
selectively build up
different parts of the tree.
So the depth-first search
way, the exhaustive search,
would have us exploring
the entire koopa tree,
and that our depth
is limited by looking
at all the possible
nodes of that level.
But what we want is we want--
because the amount of
computation required for that
explodes really quickly.
With the number of moves
that you're basically
looking into the
future, we wanted
to be able to search selectively
in certain parts of the tree.
And so for example, if there are
less promising parts over here,
then we care less about looking
into the future of those areas.
But if we have a certain move--
in chess, for example,
there's a certain move
where in two moves, you're
going to be able to take
the opponent's queen.
You're really want
to search that region
and figure out
whether that's going
to end up being a significantly
positive group for me.
And so the whole
goal of our algorithm
is going to be growing
this asymmetric tree.
How does that sound?
OK, great.
So how do we actually do this?
We're going to go over
a high-level outline,
but before we do
that, let's talk
about our tree,
which you're going
to get very familiar with.
Can people see that this
is red and this is blue?
So this is our game state
when we start our game.
We can be given a Tic-tac-toe
board with a [INAUDIBLE] place,
a game of chess with the lose
configured a certain way.
And so our player,
which is the computer,
has three separate
moves that it can take.
And so each of those moves
are presented by a node.
And each of those moves have
response moves by the opponent.
So you can imagine
that if one of these
is a Tic-tac-toe board with
just a circle, that one of these
is with that circle and
the next place right by it.
And as you go down
the this tree,
you start understanding
basically,
it's the way that humans think
about playing these games.
If I go here, then
what if they go there,
and then what if
I go right here.
You try to think through
the set of future moves
and try to evaluate
whether your move will
be good in the long term sense.
They way that are going to
expand our tree, as we said,
to create an asymmetric
tree is first of all,
we're going to descend
through the tree.
We're going to start at the
top and we're basically,
jump down some sequence of
branches until we figure out
where we're going to place
our new node, which seems
like a key operation here.
To create an asymmetric
tree it's all about how
you [INAUDIBLE].
For example, in this
case, we're going
to pick this sequence of nodes.
And once we get to the bottom
and find every location,
we're going to
create a new node.
It's not very hard.
Then we're going to simulate
a game from this new node.
And this is the
key part of MCTS.
Once you get to new
a location, what
you're going to
be doing then, is
you're going to be simulating
a game from that new location.
We're going to
talk about how you
go about simulating a game from
this more advanced game state
that what we started out with.
Does anyone have any
questions right now?
We will be going in depth
into all of these steps,
but just in a high level sense.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick question.
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: To create
the new node,
is it probabilistic, just
creating a new node as the most
probable [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: No, no.
You're creating some new node.
We'll talk about how
we pick that new node,
but we're just making a new node
and we're not thinking anything
about probability.
The next thing is that we're
going to update the tree.
So whatever the value of
the simulation delta was--
delta, remember-- we're going to
propagate that up and basically
add that to all
of the nodes that
are in that parent of
that node in the tree
and update some information
that goes in there
and that they're storing.
This is going to be good because
it's going to mean that--
it's a lot like in
search algorithms where
you have trees that then
the entirety of the tree
remains up to date with the
information from every given
simulation.
And we're just
going to repeat this
over and over and over again.
And slowly, our
tree will grow out
until whenever we
feel like stopping.
This is actually one
of the nice things
about MCTS, is that whenever
we decide that we're out
of time, like for example, if
you're in a competition playing
a champion Go player, you
can stop the simulation.
And then all you
have to do is pick
between one of the
best first moves
that you're going to make.
Because an the end of
the day, after you're
doing all the simulation,
we're still right here.
And we're still only picking
between the movies that go
immediately where we started.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could this
[INAUDIBLE] good tree?
And then on some initial
region of interest,
or is it arbitrary how
you get to create it?
PROFESSOR 3: We'll go
through how you pick
where to descend right now.
I guess, it's any
possible move that starts
at your starting game state.
Does that make-- great.
Before we move on to
the algorithm itself,
let's talk about what we store
in each one of these nodes.
So now we've added
these numbers.
And these numbers
represent is that nk,
as in the value of the
right, is the number of games
that have been played that
involve a certain node.
So for example, if
I look this node,
that means that
four games have been
played that involve this node.
A game that has been played
that involves the node
just means that
one of the states
of the board at some
point in the game
was the state of the board
that this represents.
For example, if I have a
game that was played here,
if I know that I've
played this once,
then that guarantees
to me that I
played this game
once because this is
a precursor state to this one.
Make sense?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How can the two
n's below that node not
add up to a value of [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: That will come when
we start expanding our game.
But that's a great question.
And intuitively
speaking, it should.
AUDIENCE: You're saying you're
storing data from past games
about what we've--
PROFESSOR 3: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --done before.
AUDIENCE: If past game's outside
of the script simulation?
PROFESSOR 3: No, no, no.
Past game's in the
script simulation.
And then the other
value is the number
of wins associated
with a certain node.
And these are going to be
wins for player one, which
is red in this case.
It would get confusing
if we put both of them,
but they're complementary.
So for example, three
out of the four times
that the red player visited this
node, they won in that node.
And these are the two numbers
that we're going to store.
And we're going
to see why they're
significant to store later.
So first, descending the
key part of our algorithm
that we're talking about.
And when descending,
there are these two
counterbalanced
desires that we have.
The first of them is that
we want to explore really
deeply into our tree.
We want to think about, OK, if
they do this then I'll do this.
And then, well, then I'll do
that unless I want it to forth.
And we want to think through
a long term strategy.
But at the same time, we don't
want to get caught in that.
We want to make
sure that we're not
missing a really promising
other movie that we weren't even
considering because we
were really going down
this certain rabbit
hole of the move
that we had thought
about before.
This is illustrated by the
x case [INAUDIBLE] SMBC.
The SMBC comic about academia
and how someone tells you
that a lot of really
great work has
been done in an area,
that means nothing
about how promising
the future will be.
It's all about expansion
and exploration.
And the way that we're
going to balance expansion
and exploration
in order to create
our really nice asymmetric
tree is the following formula.
And it's fine if that looks
really confusing and messy.
But actually, it breaks down
quite nicely into two parts.
This formula is
known as the UCB.
You don't need to know why it's
the Upper Confidence Bound.
Let's just talk about
what's inside it.
So first of all, you have
this term on the left.
And this term on the left
is the extension term.
It's basically proportional
to the likelihood
that the expected number of
times that you're going to win,
given that you are
in a certain node
and that you were
a certain player.
It's basically the
quality of your state
in some abstract level.
If we knew this
perfectly, then we
would be doing
great because that's
the thing we're looking for on
some grand level, The expected
likelihood of winning
from a certain state.
On the other hand, you
have this exploration term.
And you may not be able
to read the font there.
But what this is
basically saying
is that it looks at
the number of games
that I have been played through,
and it was the number of games
that my parent has
been played through.
And it tries to preserve those
numbers at a certain ratio,
at a log ratio.
And what that effectively means,
is that the number of times
that I have been--
if I have been visited
relatively few times,
and the denominator is small.
Whereas my parent has been
visited many times, which
means that my siblings have
gotten much more attention,
then the likelihood that I
will be visited again actually
increases.
So this is biased
on the one hand,
towards nodes that
are really promising,
and on the other
hand, towards nodes
that haven't been explored
yet, where there's a gold mine
and all you need to do is dig
a little bit, potentially.
We don't actually have an
analytical expression for this.
But we can approximate
it because you
can think that the expected
value from a certain node
is, roughly speaking,
approximately the ratio of wins
at that node to
the ratio of times
that that node has
been visit at all.
Let's talk about actually
applying this statement.
Because what the statement
is going to give you, is it's
going to give you some number
for here and some number
here, and some number
for here, and so on.
When we start descending
through the tree,
we're going to start
at the top node.
And then we're going
to look at the three
children of that node.
And we're going to
compute this UCB
value for each of
these children and pick
whichever one is the highest.
So just as a thought
for a moment,
what if we ignore this one?
And what if we're just
computing the UCB of these two?
Does anyone have any intuition
on whether the UCB would
be higher for this
node or for this node?
AUDIENCE: The left node.
PROFESSOR 3: The left node?
OK.
So why is that?
AUDIENCE: It has
a win [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah.
It has a win.
AUDIENCE: And they both
have a [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR 3: Exactly.
And so clearly, you think the
exploration term is the same
because you know it's not that
one child has been loved less
than the other, but
the expansion term
is going to be different.
And so it's definitely
going to pick this one.
In this case, what
we're going to say
is actually that this is so much
more promising than the others
that it's actually going
to pick this left node.
And so it's going to expand,
and it's going to look down.
And then when it
looks down, it's
going to compare
between these two.
And this time, remember,
that this is a parent.
A parent want to minimize the
number of wins that we have.
Which means that our
opponent is going
to want to pick the one that
were less likely to win in
and they're more
likely to win in.
This is the idea of
mini-max, minimizing how well
my enemy does in this game.
Although again,
the expiration term
might counterbalance it a little
bit because, technically, this
has been explored more.
We're going to pick the
one on the left again.
And we're going to
get to that location
that we got to originally.
Now when we're comparing
between these two,
between a node that
has been visited once
and a node that has
never been visited,
can anyone guess which one
of these it is going to pick?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Never
has been visited.
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah, exactly.
Because this number is zero.
And so if the
parent has ever been
visited but the node hasn't,
this is going to be infinite
and it's going to have to pick
the node that it has never
seen before.
So that's how we descend
through the tree.
Does anyone have any
questions on that.
Really, it's totally fine.
We're going to be talking
about this for a while.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: With the left node
that has the four for n sub k,
wouldn't that be three because
there's two and one below?
PROFESSOR 3: No
because of the way
that we're going to
be updating the tree.
Next, we'll talk about
some [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: I like the concept.
But if it's a deterministic
game, why couldn't it
hold it's [INAUDIBLE]
pretty strictly?
PROFESSOR 3: That's
a great question.
That's really up to
computer memory limits.
As I think that Leah
mentioned, the number of stakes
in the game of Go--
it's a 19 by 19 board,
and you can play something
at every state.
It's only like 2 to the--
PROFESSOR 2: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: What?
PROFESSOR 2: 250.
PROFESSOR 3: 250.
You could never explore
the entire search tree.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
over the first few layers
or are we going polite.
We try to do this real
time where you could
have done something offline.
PROFESSOR 3: It's
definitely true.
If you know a state
that you're going
to arrive at ahead of time,
then you can totally do that.
But in a game
that's large enough
that to do that for
all the possible states
would take that much more time
and take that much more memory.
It doesn't end up
making that much sense.
Also, something
to point out here,
is that for most of the games
that we're talking about,
simulating a run through
of the game is really fast.
So if you think about it--
let's actually get to
that in next piece.
But the point is
that building up
this many levels of
a tree for a computer
takes probably on the order
of less than millisecond.
So doing this for a
really, really huge tree,
it's peanuts because their
such simple operations.
But it won't get expensive
when we start building up
the tree to serious depths.
AUDIENCE: But a game like Go,
how many nodes would you have?
PROFESSOR 3: On each
level, in the beginning,
we have something on
the order of 400 nodes.
And we have a depth
of about, I think
most games have up to 250
steps, or something like that.
AUDIENCE: So just to build,
if you go in there blank,
without any nodes built,
you have to in the computer,
like you said, it
hasn't visited a node,
it has to go there before
it descends further.
Basically, like breadth first.
PROFESSOR 3: It's sort of like
breadth first but not quite.
There's an important
distinction here,
which is that it doesn't have
to build up this or this node.
It doesn't have to build
up all of the nodes
at a certain level.
All it has to do is, if it
branches down to a certain sub
region, then can't
descend in that sub region
below one of its siblings
without having at least looked
once at all its siblings.
After it looks once it
can do whatever it wants.
And the point is,
that it doesn't
mean the tree has to be
kept at an even level.
All it means is that
the tree, in order
to descend on a specific
part of the tree,
it has to have at least visited
direct neighbors once before.
Any more questions
on this before--
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's the
advantage necessarily
of having to visit every single?
PROFESSOR 3: The
advantage of having
to visit every single--
the way that I think of it,
is that you don't
want to be missing out
on potentially being interested
in some of the things
and not others.
It comes back to the exploration
versus expectation distinction.
We do want to descend into
the region of the tree that
is really valuable to us.
But at least have
explored a little bit,
at least maintaining
some baseline,
which really isn't
that costly compared
to the size of the tree.
400 moves is not that bad
compared with 400 and 250.
AUDIENCE: Are these
simulations, they're
just random simulations?
PROFESSOR 3: We're going to
talk about that in a minute.
Any more questions
before I move onto that?
Next step is expanding.
And this is very simple.
You just create a node and you
set the two initial values.
And the initial
values are the number
of times it's been
visited is zero,
and then number of times that
someone has won from there
is zero.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] So
the easy part is solving it.
PROFESSOR 3: Now, simulating.
Simulating is really hard.
You can imagine that if
you get to a single node
and you've never seen
that node before,
and you don't know what to
do from this node onward,
that if we knew how the
game was going to play out,
that is exactly what
were searching for,
and we would be done.
But we don't.
And in fact, we have no idea
how to go about simulating
a realistic game,
and a game that
will tell us something
meaningful about the quality
of a certain state.
And so, as you
correctly guessed,
we're going to do it randomly.
We're going to be
at a certain state.
And then from that
state, we're just
going to pick random nodes
for each of the players
until the game ends.
And if we, as player one, win
then we're going to add one.
Then we're going to say
delta equals plus one.
And if we don't win,
or if we tie or lose,
then we're going
to call it a zero.
You can in this graph, we're
descending randomly and not
thinking about it.
And it turns out that
this is actually great
because it's really, really
computationally efficient.
If you have a board, even
if it has 400 open squares,
populating it by a
bunch of random moves
doesn't take you very
long, on the order
of not that many machine can.
AUDIENCE: That's why
does you don't score--
if you go down a tree randomly,
you already have a simulation.
So the node's going
to get to someplace.
But you don't store it because
it would lose the randomness?
PROFESSOR 3: You're totally
right, actually, in this case.
I've thought through this, and
I can't come up with a reason
why you wouldn't
store it, that's
it's temporary values that you
find all the way down the tree.
But they don't in most of
the literature [INAUDIBLE]
But you're totally
right about that.
Does everyone understand
that distinction?
The fact that we only
hold onto the result
here and don't
theoretically make
nodes for every place down in
the tree just because we could,
just because we've
seen them before.
We don't, and it doesn't
really matter in this case.
But it's theoretically a slight
speed up that you could do.
AUDIENCE: But you reduce that
question to generalities?
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah, a little bit.
So we can look at an example of
simulating out a running game.
We get some intuition for
why a random game would
be correlated with how good
your board position is.
For example, here we
have a Detecto game.
Circle is going to move next.
But as hopefully you can
see, because you have played
Detecto before, this is not a
particularly promising board
for x.
Because no matter
what circle does,
if x is an intelligent
player x can win right now.
It has two different
options for winning.
And so, if you simulated this
forward randomly, what you'll
get is that 2/3 of the
time, x will in fact win,
even if the players
aren't really
thinking of it ahead of time.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Then why
not do n simulations
at a node instead of
just a single simulation?
PROFESSOR 3: You
totally can do that.
That's in fact, something
that make sense to do
and that some people do.
Although what you'll
find somewhat soon,
is that considering that
we're going down the tree,
and that sometimes
soon we're going
to explore all of
its children, there's
a good question of why
you end simulations now
when you could just descend
through the tree n times
and thereby do n simulations
by going through the thing
and also building
out the children?
This case is-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: This gives
more importance
to why you do randomness.
Because if you're doing
random simulations
you would ignore the
possibility of the best one.
When you first ran a simulation
here was that o wins.
If I ignore this node--
PROFESSOR 3: Absolutely.
Which is why it matters that we
do this so many times that we
drown out all the noise that
is associated with playing
a game out randomly.
Let's talk about that.
If there's a lot of distance
between where we are right now
and our end result--
For example, in
this game, if I were
to tell you how good is this
board position, if you are one
of those people who played
out every game of Detecto,
you'll know that this is
great if you want it to be
[INAUDIBLE]
Anyway, the point
is, that is not
easy to do if you are doing
random simulations from where
you start.
The correlation between
your friend's board state
and the quality of that state
actually drops precipitously.
And this for me is one
of the hardest parts
to study about Monte
Carlo Tree Search.
Although, as Nick
will explain to you,
it actually works quite well.
And one of the reasons that it
works quite well in practice
for more complicated
applications
is they do away
with the assumption
of random simulation.
Because even the
random simulations
does allow you to explore
all the states, if you have
some idea of where a reasonable
quality approach would be,
then using that, as long as it's
not that much more expensive
computationally, can help
you with your simulation.
Right now we're still talking
about total randomness.
How are people doing
with that idea?
Now we're going to update
the tree with the results
of our simulation.
So given that we had
some result lambda,
we're going to try to
get up the parents.
And for each parent
we're going to add
that the game has been
played there once,
and that the result
of that simulation
gets added if it was a one.
So for example, if there
was a win in this game,
than this becomes one, one
because now it's won once
and it's been visited once.
And these two get
incremented by one,
and these two get
incremented by one.
That in itself comprises
a complete iteration,
the complete single iteration
of running Monte Carlo Tree
Search, which means that
now we can keep doing this
over and over again,
building up the tree
and slowly making it
deeper, and making it deeper
in selective areas.
And having these numbers
increase and increase.
And be more and
more proportional
to the actual expected value
of the quality of the state,
until--
does anyone have any
questions about this idea?--
until we terminate.
And we have to come up
with a way to terminate it.
Now again, we said we're going
to pick what the best child is
going to be, what the best
immediate move from the start
state is going to be.
That's the move that were
actually going to play.
And so, how do we
determine what the best is?
Well, the trivial solution
is just the highest
expected win given k.
What that, in our
case, is going to be
is the ratio of number
of times that I've
win from a given early
state to the number of times
that I visited.
However, this doesn't actually
work as well as we might hope.
Let's suppose the
following scenario,
which is that you have the
Detecto game like this.
And you have been exploring
the tree for a while.
And you're really mostly
looking at these two nodes.
One of these nodes, if
you think it through,
this node is quite
promising and you've
been exploring it for a while.
There is a winning
strategy from this node.
It's that circle goes
here, and then x goes here,
and then circle loses because
x has two options to win.
However, if you explore
this a bunch of times,
and for some reason,
due to the randomness,
this is at 11 out of 20.
Whereas this state, which
is inherently inferior,
is at three out of five because
of a bunch of randomness
and because it hasn't
been explored as much.
And if we had looked at
this one as exhaustively
we had at this one,
that you probably
would actually say that this
state is actually better.
And so, you can create
an alternative criteria,
which is that it's the
highest expected win
value of one of the children.
But also, that value
has to be the node that
has been most visited
so that they aren't
explored by different amounts.
What this sacrifice
is however, is
that this means that we
can't terminate on demand.
This is not always
going to be true,
and therefore, we're going
to have to let the algorithm
run until that's true for
some start state, which
means that maybe is not
a criteria that we want
to apply even though we know
that it would be wise to do so.
Are there any
questions about how
we pick the terminating guide?
That was the whole thing.
And now we're going to do
it lots and lots of times
until you guys are sick of
Monte Carlo Tree Search.
So this our tree.
It's more or less
what we've had before.
The first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to
look at the top.
And then we're going to
pick one of these children.
Now let's say that
we looked at this,
and it turns out that the one
on the left is really valuable.
I think it's the one.
Nope, yeah.
Never mind.
It's wrong.
The one on the left
has been explored
a whole bunch of times.
Remember, this term
starts becoming larger
than the ones that haven't
been visited as much.
And so we're going to
descend from this one.
And now we're going to descend,
and we have these two options.
Given what you know,
would you expect
that this is going
to pick is going
to be the one on the right
or the one on the left?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: On the
right because it's never
been visited before.
And so, this term
is going to explode.
And so, we're going
to build a node there.
And then we're going
to simulate a game.
And the result is a win,
which is bad for this player.
That means that he probably
didn't want to make that move.
And so we're going to
propagate that value up.
And we're going to start
the algorithm again.
And it's going to compare
between these three.
And now it's going to
pick the one on the left.
Now that it picked
the one on the left,
it going to compare
between these two states.
Which of the two is going to
have a higher expansion factor?
AUDIENCE: The left.
AUDIENCE: Don't you
invert it, though,
because this is the opponent.
PROFESSOR 3: Exactly.
Because two out of three
is actually better.
Because it's one out of
three for the opponent
that's currently
making the move.
So the one on the left is going
to have a higher expansion
factor, and the
one on the right is
going to have a higher
exploration factor.
Does that make sense for people?
It's OK if it doesn't.
So we're actually going to
pick the one on the right
because the other one was
is doing three and has lots
of it's mother's
love than that one's.
Anyone else need a drink?
We're going to expand that node.
It doesn't matter.
They are both equally
likely to be expanded.
We're going to simulate forward,
and it's going to be one.
Which means that that was
probably a wise countermove.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when it's
the opponent's turn
versus your turn, the
exploration factor
is the same but we complement
the expansion factor, right?
PROFESSOR 3: Yes.
So the key here
being that this takes
in both the state that
you're talking about
and the player that
you're talking about.
AUDIENCE: But regardless
of the player,
the exploration factor will
always be like this is.
PROFESSOR 3: Because it's only
the number of visits it's.
It has nothing to do with
results of exploration.
AUDIENCE: If you win and
you have the plus one,
double plus one, and
you've propagated out,
but I'm wondering--
so if the opponent wins
do you also propagate
out the win increment itself?
If the opponent's
winning, wouldn't you
want to [INAUDIBLE] node here?
PROFESSOR 3: If the
opponent wins then what you
do is you propagate up a zero.
Which means that wk is not
incremented, but nk is.
Have we seen a zero yet?
There's one soon.
But the idea is that rather
than subtract or anything,
all you do is propagate
up the result of the game,
which in this case is zero.
Which means that
all of those states
seems to become more valuable
to the blue and less valuable
to the red.
Because these numbers are
lower than the other ones were.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR 3: So we
propagate this up
and this becomes better.
What we've done here
is we've figured out
a theoretical countermove
to blue moving here.
That's how you should think
about this whole tree.
It's really a lot like
the way the humans think
about these things.
If I do this, then
what if they do this?
Well, then I'll do this.
And I see that I'm
successful when I do that.
We're going to look
again at the top.
And we're going to pick
the one on the left
because it's really promising.
Five out of six
is a good number.
And we're going to
look at both sides.
And which one is blue
going to pick now?
Well, it's going to
pick the one that it's
going to be more successful
in, which is two out of three.
I realize that this is
actually not the kind of thing
where I could
necessarily ask people
because I'm the one who's
decided which node to stop.
Then we go down here.
And there's an equal
likelihood of picking
either of those nodes.
And so we're going to
pick one at random.
So that's going to
be the left one.
And we're going to
create an empty node.
Then we're going to play it out.
And it was a success
for blue, which
is amazing because what this
means now is that suddenly,
in this tree of this really
good move that red could make
the blue wasn't find a
response to, suddenly
there's hope because we're
going to propagate this back.
And that means
that blue actually
has a response move to that
sequence of red's moves.
And so it's going
to propagate up.
And this state's going to be
more promising to blue and less
promising of red.
That region of the tree
that we had dug into
is a little less promising.
We're going to look back up.
And this time,
instead, we're going
to evaluate the thing
that is both promising
from the expansion
factor, and also
promising because
we haven't looked
at it very much [INAUDIBLE]
exploration factor.
We're going to pick
between these two.
Which one is going
to be picked here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: Because the
exploration factor is the same
but the expansion factor is
higher for the one on the left.
And it's going to
show us a node.
And the result is going to
be a win for a red, which
means that red has found a good
countermove to the thing that
was previously
promising for blue.
And we propagate it back up.
And finally, we're going to pick
the one furthest on the right.
Because even though
it's terrible for red,
and even though it's never
won when it's tried it,
it has to obey his idea
of the exploration mode
to find out whether maybe there
isn't something possible there.
So it explores,
and it goes down,
and it has to pick
the one on the right.
And so it does.
And it plays this game out.
And it's a loss, again.
Which goes to show
you, that blue
has found yet
another superior move
to this really bad
move of red, where
probably this move of red,
if this is a game of chess,
is like putting
my queen directly
in front of the
opponent's row of pawns,
and I just leave it there.
There's nothing good that's
ever going to come of it
but we have to explore
it just to find out
whether there isn't some magical
way that I should protect.
And as you can see,
we've built up this tree
over and over and over again.
And it's starting
to look asymmetric.
And we're starting to
see that there's really
this disparity between exploring
the regions that are crossing
this tree and exploring
the regions that are not
and that don't really
matter to us very much.
And that this is exactly what we
wanted from Monte Carlo trees.
That was why we started
the whole endeavor
in the first place.
The next thing I'm going to
talk about is the pros and cons.
But before I do
that, does anyone
have any more questions
about the algorithm?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's still not
clear how we're getting nodes
with different denominators--
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: The reason for
that is because of the way
that we're simulating through.
We're actually not holding
onto to the results
of the simulation as we're
going farther down the tree
than the lowest node we expand.
For example, when you
simulate from here,
you're going to propagate that
value here and here, and so on.
But then when we
expand below, even
if in the course of
this guy's simulation
it happened to go
through one of the states
that we expanded
below, it will not
have incremented the
values of that state
because we weren't
keeping track of it.
Theoretically, if
we were to keep
track of all of the simulations
that we have in fact run,
the numbers beneath these
things would be higher.
AUDIENCE: If you've already
run a simulation from that--
if you've already
run a simulation
from that red node when
you first built it,
and then when you created those
two ones, each of those have
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: OK.
I see.
AUDIENCE: So would
the denominator always
be one more than the
sum of the children?
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah,
in [INAUDIBLE] Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I understand
how you built that.
Is there a rule of thumb, like
it's time to choose a move?
And it seems like you
have very low numbers here
to make a [INAUDIBLE]
Is there a rule of
thumb on giving games
like it's 2 to the 4 or 2
to the 350, whatever it is.
What kind of numbers do
you need for that first row
before you [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR 3: What we'll get
to soon is that isn't one.
That's one of the
problem with MCTS.
But in terms of which of
the moves you will choose,
there are actually variants of
MCTS that suggest that you more
selectively age or
insert new children based
on something more than just
the blind look right now.
In terms of, if I'm here and
it's creating my next children
as the equivalent, then there
are some intelligent guesses
that you can make in
terms of which one
you should score first.
Although it doesn't
particularly matter.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
saying computational time
being what it is,
you might say, OK,
if this is the timeline
of this game I can expect
to do a million simulations,
which will give me
if there's 400 nodes, I'm
going to have so much use.
In other words, is
that enough time
to say that I can
play through a game?
I couldn't play through
a game with 400 options
if I've gotten five out
of seven [INAUDIBLE]
three out of four [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: Absolutely.
And I would say that
so far as I know,
that's something
that's basically very
high experimentally.
They don't have
good balance on it.
[INAUDIBLE]
So let's get on
the first comment
because that is a
computer element.
So why should you
use this algorithm?
Even though we've seen
tremendous breakthroughs
in this algorithm,
and you're going
to have to ignore
everything that I tell you
and remember that
this does actually
work quite well in
certain scenarios.
Should we use it or not?
The pros are that it
actually does the thing
that we want it to do.
It grows the tree
asymmetrically.
It means that we do
not have to explore.
And it doesn't
explode exponentially
with the number of moves that
we're looking into the future.
And that it selectively grows
the tree towards the areas that
are most promising.
The other huge
benefit, if you'll
notice from what we've
just talked through,
is that it never
relies on anything
other than the strict
rules of the game.
What that means is that the
only weight of the game that's
factored in is that the
game is what tells us
what the next moves we can
take from a given state are,
and whether a given state
is a victory or a defeat.
And that's kind of
amazing because we
had no external heuristic
information about this game.
Which means that if I
took a completely new game
that someone had just invented,
and I plugged MCTS into it,
MCTS would be a slightly or
someone competitive player
for this game, which
is a powerful idea.
It leads to our next two pros.
The first of which is that it's
very easy to adapt to new games
that it hasn't seen
before, or even that people
haven't seen before.
This is clearly valuable.
But the other nice
thing about it
is that even though
heuristics are not
required to make MCTS
work [INAUDIBLE],,
it can work [INAUDIBLE].
There are a number
of [? advanced ?]
places in the algorithm
that you can actually
incorporate heuristics into.
Nick is going to talk about how
AlphaGo uses this very heavily.
AlphaGo is not vanilla Go.
It has a lot of
external information
that's built into the
way that it works.
But MCTS is a framework-- you
can imagine your heuristics you
can apply in the
simulation, there
are heuristics you can
apply in the UCB in the way
that we choose the next node.
There are places
that it can fit in.
And this services as a nice
infrastructure to do so.
The other benefit is that it's
an on demand algorithm, which
is particularly valuable when
you're under some sort of time
pressure, when you're competing
against someone that's
a mathematician, or when
something is about to explode
and you have to make a decision
on which reactor to shut down.
And lastly-- or not
lastly, actually, it's
complete, which is
really nice because you
know that if you run
this game for long enough
it's going to start looking
at a lot like a BFS tree.
No, it's actually
going to start looking
like an alpha-beta tree, if
it is what it is converted to.
It's a nice property to have.
Although, this
property does slightly
get compromised if you
remove the red in this idea,
and if only simulate
these [INAUDIBLE]..
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: You made
an interesting comment
when you said, oh, it
looks like -beta tree.
So it looked like
a mini-max tree.
But have they also
incorporated notions
of pruning in the
MCTS, which would make
it look like an -beta tree?
PROFESSOR 3: Sorry,
you're completely right.
It does look like
a mini-max tree.
I think I've seen variants
where they do pruning,
but I haven't looked
into it as much.
But I would imagine
that they would
converge to whatever
you know pruning
a certain tree [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: But people have
explored incorporating pruning
into MCTS?
PROFESSOR 3: I think so.
I can't say [INAUDIBLE]
And then lastly, it's
really parallelizable.
You'll notice, none of
the regions of this tree,
other than the
original choice, ever
have to interact
with each other.
So if you have 200
processors and you decide,
OK, I'm going to break up this
tree in the first 200 decisions
and then have each
one of those flesh
out one of those decisions, that
actually means that they can
all combine information
right at the end
and make a decision
[INAUDIBLE],, which
is a really nice, powerful
principle as you [INAUDIBLE]..
It does have its fair
share of problems.
The first problem being
that it does breakdown
under extreme tree depth.
The main reason for this
being that as you increase
more moves between you
and the end of the game,
you're increasing
the probability--
you are decreasing the
correlation between your game
state and whether a
random playoff would
suggest that you're in a good
position or a bad position.
The same goes for
branching factors.
One of the things that people
sometimes talk about it
as if MCTS AI's cannot
play first-person shooters
because the distance between the
number of things that you can
do at every given moment, and
what would be a successful
approach in the long term
after meeting many, many,
many moves that each have
many branching factors,
is that never begins to explore
the size of the search tree.
For the most part, it's
not really coming up
with a long term policy.
It's really thinking about what
are the next sequence of moves
that I should [INAUDIBLE].
Another problem is
that it requires
simulation to be very
easy and very repeatable.
So for example, if we
wanted to tell our AI,
how do I take over Ontario?
There's not a
particularly good way
that you can simulate
taking over Ontario?
If you try it once,
you're not going
to have an opportunity
to try it again,
at least with the same
set of configurations.
And actually, one of the things
that we really took advantage
of, if that random simulation
happens really quickly,
on the order of microseconds.
On other hand, the
bigger your computational
resources that you
have access to,
the better the algorithm works.
That means that I can't run it
off my Mac particularly well.
It would be like large games.
It relies on this tenuous
assumption of random play
be weakly correlated with the
quality of our game state.
And this is one of the
first assumptions that
is going to be thrown out the
window for a lot of the more
advanced MCTS approaches,
which are going to have
more intelligent play outs.
But those are going to
lose some of the generality
that we had before.
Something that goes off of that
is that MCTS is a framework.
But in order to actually make
it effective for a lot of games
it does require a lot of
tuning, in the sense that there
are a whole bunch of variants.
And that you need to be
able to implement whatever
flavor is best suited for you.
Which means that it's not
quite as nice and black boxy
as we would want it to be
as far as give it the rules
and have it magically come up
with a strategy [INAUDIBLE]..
And then lastly,
as you mentioned,
there is not a great amount
of literature right now
about the properties of
MCTS and its convergence,
and what the actual
proportion of time
to quality of your solution is.
This is true of all modern
machine learning things,
is that there is certainly a lot
more work that could be done.
But right now,
that's a gap in terms
of using this for a simulation
that's supposed to be reliable.
Anyone have any questions
on the Pros and Cons?
Before we jump dive
into applications,
let's talk through
a few examples
of what games could be
solved and could not
be solved by MCTS.
Do you guys think that
checkers is a game that
could be solved by MCTS?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR 3: It's
completely deterministic.
It's two-player.
It satisfies all of the criteria
that we've laid out before.
Checkers is
definitely a game that
can and has been solved by
MCTS, although not solved
to the extent that you can
defeat the thing that actually
has the solution [INAUDIBLE].
How about "Settlers of Catan?"
This one's a little
bit trickier.
Do you guys think that MCTS
is likely to be able to play
"Settlers of Catan?"
If not, let's throw out reason
why or why not it would be
[INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: No because
there's randomness.
PROFESSOR 3: So yes, that
is absolutely the criticism.
And that's why we
can't apply it vanilla.
I put this on here
as a trick question,
though, because it
turns out that MCTS
is robust to randomness.
That you can actually play--
and I realize that's
just me and we do.
[LAUGHTER]
You can actually
play through games.
If you think about
the simulation,
the simulation is
actually applicable
even if the game is
not deterministic
because it does give you
a sense of the quality
of your position.
And the MCTS-based
AI to play "Settlers"
is, I think, at least 49%
competitive with the best AI
to play, at least in the
autonomous non-scale space.
So it does work.
Let's talk about the war
operations plan response.
Who here has seen the
movie "War Games?"
OK.
Well, it should be more of you.
The idea of "War
Games" is that one
of the core characters
in this world
is this computer
that has been put
in charge of the national
defense strategy with respect
to Russia.
And that it needs to think
through the possible future
scenarios and decide whether
it's going to launch the nukes
or not.
Do you think that WOPR
can be MCTS-based?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR 3: No.
AUDIENCE: It could, it
just wouldn't be very good.
PROFESSOR 3: Absolutely.
Once you fire the
nukes you're not
going to get another chance.
So you can't
particularly simulate
through what the possible
scenarios are going to be like.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what if you had--
I agree you can't simulate
it in the real world.
But what if you had
a really good model
and you just simulated
based on that model?
PROFESSOR 3: In that
case, it probably depends
on the quality of your model.
If you have a good model for
how World War III is going to
[INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: It is the case
that the military does
have simulators and they
do war games in simulation.
PROFESSOR 3: Yes, that's true.
They could certainly try it
and run MCTS if they wanted.
And that's what
happened in the movie.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: And there
you're putting your money
in the simulation not in the--
AUDIENCE: It's like having an
MCTS play SOCOM or something
like that.
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah.
It's definitely about putting
money into the simulation
and you get really
good simulation.
If you have a really
good simulations then you
[INAUDIBLE] to play WOPR.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Back to
"Settlers" for a second.
I'm curious if there's a way
for the whole player training
resources thing,
or would it have
to be only purely
like using the ports.
PROFESSOR 3: That's
a good question.
I haven't looked closely at
whether they do that or not.
If it's playing a
two-player game,
then I would imagine that they
wouldn't because you don't
really trade in to play a game.
But if they weren't,
I bet that you
can incorporate it with WOPR.
AUDIENCE: Is it limited
to two-player games?
PROFESSOR 3: No, not at all.
In fact, there are
lots of purchases
that do only
one-player games, where
you think of what's the best
movie that you can make.
AUDIENCE: I know.
But I mean, couldn't MCTS handle
three- or four-player games?
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah,
it absolutely could.
I'm not sure how they
computed their head-to-head.
That might be
completely flat cursors.
I'm not even sure how
the settlers interact.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A quick question.
So at first you know if I
reduce the chess board to only 4
by 4 or 5 by 5, and
I run MCTS versus
the traditional algorithm that
AlphaGo offered as a tree.
Do you think MCTS will
prefer theory and perform
this computational requirement.
PROFESSOR 3: The thing about
the way that Deep Blue is,
which is the AI that
ended the Kasparov
thing, a bunch of his
chess grand master,
is that it has a tremendous
amount of heuristic
information.
There's a lot of
external stuff that's
incorporated into the
system that makes it
able to explore the best paths.
What I would say is
that knoledgesless
MCTS based on randomness,
would take a very long
computational time to even
become competitive with those
kinds of algorithms, and
probably feasibly never would.
What if you incorporated
heuristic information,
I think that there's a bunch of
hope in terms of getting MCTS
to start performing better.
And you can look at what
next I'm going to talk about,
AlphaGo.
It takes inspiration for how
we go about incorporating
these new circuits.
AUDIENCE: So only the
circuit you [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: It definitely
seems like if you
have a really good
heuristic model for what
good states in the game are,
that if it's a smaller search
space, that some other
models could perform better.
Although, I'm probably
going to eat my foot here
because this is going to be
on OCW some massive amount,
massive chess
playing algorithms.
Eat my shoe not my foot.
[LAUGHTER]
One last game.
Does anyone know
what this game is?
AUDIENCE: "Total War?"
PROFESSOR 3: Yes.
Nice.
This is "Rome, Total War II."
It's a simulator for this
tremendous real time strategy
game, where you play, I
think, the Roman Empire.
And you're controlling armies
and huge infrastructure systems
that move and conquer
states and continents,
and meet in the field, and
manage resources, and do
all of these incredible
diplomacy feats.
And so do you think that this
game can be solved by MCTS?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR 3: Lets say no.
But I guess I put it on here.
So that's good on you.
The way that the AI in
"Rome, Total War II" is built
is that it's built
on an MCTS structure.
And it in fact does
do resource allocation
and a lot of its
political maneuvers
based on Monte Carlo
Tree Search moves.
There are a bunch of
reasons that they explain
in the game for
why they do this,
or in papers released
about the game.
But one of the nice ones
is that it's random,
which means that
you're never going
to play against the same kind
of AI twice because every time
the set of decisions that
it's going to think about
is completely different.
AUDIENCE: I have
a quick question.
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if I want to
model any game with MCTS,
does it have to be that the
actions in playing a game
has to be able to discretize.
PROFESSOR 3: Yes.
So far as I know, I haven't
seen many continuous variants
in MCTS.
And so, I think that it is about
choosing these reactions, which
on it's most narrow level does
actually bring it down to here.
I think one of the
reasons that this
is nice is that there are so
many different decisions that
could be made that MCTS is
really the only approach that
could even begin to handle the
massive branching factor that's
associated with the
game Rome, Total War.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This is
also the consequence
of this year you get the play
off when this game comes.
PROFESSOR 3: That's interesting.
That's probably totally it.
That's cool.
That's everything about how
the algorithm actually works.
I'm going to pass
it off to Nick,
and he's going to talk to us
about some actual limitations
for this game [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 3: So
as you have said,
I'm going to start diving
into some applications here.
And not only applications
but also some modifications
or augmentations of MCTS.
It should hopefully clarify
some of the side questions
you all have been having
on slight tweaks to MCTS.
Now let's get started.
Wait for it.
[LAUGHTER]
Part III, applications.
First thing we're
going to look at
is an MCTS-based
"Mario" controller.
And "Mario" might seem like
some weird thing to test AI on,
but there actually is a "Super
Mario Bros" AI benchmark,
which it used to
test a lot of AI
on how well they could
play this platform.
In case any of you don't
know what "Super Mario
Bros" is, this is a screenshot.
Basically, you control
this one character.
It's a single-player game.
The ultimate goal is to
reach this flag at the end.
But along the way
there's enemies,
there's some bonus
shrooms you can get.
If you break open some
boxes you might get coins,
things like that.
But first, let's just highlight
some of the modifications that
need to be made, or some of
the differences between vanilla
MCTS and an MCTS that's going
to be able to work for "Mario."
First thing is that
it's single-player.
The second is, we use a
slightly different simulation
strategy than the initial
just vanilla simulation.
And someone actually hinted at
doing more than one simulation
because you, you're watching
us to n simulations, I think.
We'll touch on that.
Then this also introduces
what I would consider
to be domain knowledge.
Then finally, there's a 50 to
40 millisecond computation time.
And that has to do with the
frames per second of the game.
So you would think that
"Mario" is a continuous game,
but if we discretize
time into these chunks,
then we can use MTTS.
Now let's just think about
how we could possibly
formulate this problem.
Can anyone think of
what each of these nodes
would be if we're
playing "Super Mario?"
AUDIENCE: Jump.
PROFESSOR 3: Sorry?
It would be like, first
node you're going to jump.
PROFESSOR 3: That might
be a way to formulate it.
But I think that could get--
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's not your
control at inputs [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR 3: Right.
So the node itself isn't
going to be an action.
AUDIENCE: Equal frames.
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah, basically.
So it's going to be the
state of a game, what
we'll call a state.
So it's basically
just a screen grab.
And it take it,
in this case, it's
a 15 by 19 grid screen
grab of the game.
And it will have
information about-- it
knows Mario's position, it knows
the enemy's position, position
of the blocks, et cetera.
And then, as Yo
was saying, in MCTS
we have values associated
with our nodes.
And so it will
also have a value.
But we'll get into the
value in the next slide
because I can't really
fit it all in here.
With that being said
for our node, that
being the state of the game,
what makes sense for the edge?
Does anyone know?
How do we transition from
one state to another state?
AUDIENCE: Jump.
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah, exactly.
So this is where the
jump and all the action
have been played.
So the actions that you take--
I didn't list all the actions.
You can also have a jump left,
jump right, all those things.
But basically, the
actions are what
takes you from state to state.
So I just drew out
what a node might
look like if you
used the jump action.
You might have Mario
go up in the sky.
Are there questions?
AUDIENCE: Does it just
run the rest of it?
Because that little thing's
moving as they move on?
PROFESSOR 3: Well, it's not
moving in this moment in time.
We're discretizing
time right now.
AUDIENCE: But I'm saying,
if your action is jump,
just you would have 1,000
nodes because if you did
plan out where that thing's
moving, left or right,
then it could be--
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah, right.
So in each state we
have the enemy position.
And we know the
speed and direction.
And so we know when we go from
this node to one time step
later, we'll know where
the enemy's moving.
Any other questions?
Moving on.
Sorry.
Let me just preface
this part real quick.
So in our other simulations,
at the end of the simulation
we would get either a one or a
zero, if we'd won tic-tac-toe
or we lost tic-tac-toe.
But that won't really work
too well here because there's
a lot of other factors
that go into play when
you're playing "Mario."
Also, if you're doing a
simulation, more than likely,
you're going to end
up hitting an enemy
and dying or falling
into a gap and dying.
So a lot of these simulations
might all return zero.
And that is, you can't really
distinguish between them.
So this is why I say,
this version of MCTS
introduces what I would
consider to be domain knowledge.
Basically, they're
assigning scores
to potential things that
could happened along the way.
And this is basically telling
the AI that collecting a flower
is a little bit better
than collecting a mushroom.
It's telling it that
getting hurt is bad.
Right off the bat, all
these things in the score
are giving the AI some domain
knowledge about "Super Mario
Bros," that it's helping
it calculate the simulation
results.
As it says here, it's just doing
a multi-objective weighted sum
of all these things.
Throughout the simulation it's
just adding up your score.
And then that's the score that
is going to be propagated.
Are there questions
about the score?
AUDIENCE: You said that
it adds up all these guys
and it propagates it over.
Is it possible to just propagate
the multi-part sum [INAUDIBLE]
as opposed to propagating
one value that you create?
Are you essentially
propagating all--
what's this?-- 15 values
upwards at every node, or are
you propagating one value--
PROFESSOR 3: Well,
it's one value.
It's the collective--
AUDIENCE: Then you make
them add it together
and you got each one
of them a sub factor.
PROFESSOR 3: Then also,
just one thing to note here,
is distance, you get 0.1.
And these are all parameters
that have been tuned.
In the initial version,
distance was, I think,
a reward of five,
but probably realized
that that made Mario skip past
a lot of coins and things.
And so he tweaked
the score for that.
And also, time left is two.
So there's some weight there.
You want to get to the
very end of the game.
AUDIENCE: If you're
pushing up this score,
it's no longer a
win over losses.
So it's not w over n.
What is it affecting?
PROFESSOR 3: You can
just use the score.
AUDIENCE: The score is the--
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah.
In MCTS you have
this idea of when
you're propagating your q value,
you could have that to be zero,
one.
AUDIENCE: It's like the sum of
all the scores and the nodes
below over the number
of games you win.
PROFESSOR 3: So
basically, what you
would be getting when you divide
by the number of simulations
is your average
score at that node.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: When you have
killsByFire and [INAUDIBLE]
like that, if you
have a positive value,
then isn't it good
to be killed by fire,
or something like that?
PROFESSOR 3: This is
killing an enemy by fire.
Like Mario could collect a
certain flower or mushroom?
I think flower, then you
have a fire breath and you
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So that's Mario's
status if Mario never dies?
PROFESSOR 3: No.
Mario's status is--
I believe, Mario's
status is the fact
that you could upgrade Mario by
collecting [INAUDIBLE] mushroom
from a fire Mario.
So that gives you
a lot of points.
Because if you
become fire Mario,
then you're more likely to not
die by running into enemies
because you have fire-spewing--
AUDIENCE: You said they
spent a lot of time
tuning these parameters.
Isn't it generally, though,
just an optimization
framework if that's
some formula?
So they tuned the
parameters just
to make behave the way
that we think is nice.
But if you change
the values, they'll
do the right thing
for that equation.
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR 3: Yes.
But they were tuning this to
make it play how they wanted.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] can't just
be a reflection of [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: That's a strategy.
If you choose that,
I don't see why not.
That might affect
certain things.
Obviously, you can change
these to whatever you want.
It'll slightly tweak
which simulations
as to working better, in terms
of changing which nodes you
end up choosing [INAUDIBLE].
So we move on.
So we know about
scoring simulations.
Now we're going to look at
exactly the simulation type
that's used to play
this MCTS controller.
So the regular version
that Yo talked about
is just choosing a
random node at each level
in your simulation.
But there are some
other strategies.
And someone brought one up.
The first is, look at best of n.
So in this one, you choose three
random nodes at each level,
except that you stick with
the best of those three.
Choose three random nodes,
stick with this one.
Go to the next one.
You would choose n random
three, take the best one,
and then go to the next level.
You are able to do that
in this game because
of the way the
scoring works, you
don't have to get to the end
of the game for your score.
You actually could collect
a coin along the way.
If this is jump,
and then it gets
to be a coin versus
moving left and right.
That doesn't give
you any points.
Then this is the node that would
give you the highest scores,
so I would choose
that one, et cetera.
And then the final one,
which is the one that
is actually used
for this controller,
is multi-simulation.
This was brought up by him.
I don't know your name.
Sorry.
But basically, you run
multiple random simulations
from your node.
And then you propagate up
whichever of those simulations
give you the highest value.
And the reason to do
multiple simulations
is to attempt to increase the
accuracy of your simulations.
If you just do
one simulation you
might just get really lucky.
But if you do three then you
can take the highest value
use that as your value.
Since the whole point of this is
to try make moves that get you
the highest values,
then that will
make your random simulation
value more accurate.
Are there questions
about multi-simulation?
AUDIENCE: So what do you
think about the simulation
[INAUDIBLE] how many [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: So there's
a trade off here.
The more simulations you
do the more accurate--
the more representative
your simulation
will be at the end of the game.
You could run two to
the whatever simulations
to try to get every
single possible action
and then take the max of that.
And that would give
you the maximum value.
That would be ideal.
But obviously, that
takes more time.
So there's a trade off
between computation time
and the number of
simulations you run.
And that's just something
that they probably just
played around with.
AUDIENCE: Do you
use [INAUDIBLE] have
to finish the decision losing a
couple of minutes or 10 minutes
or they're going to take
your [INAUDIBLE] away.
PROFESSOR 3: In this competition
there is different computation
time budgets that you get.
And I believe the reason for
the different computation time
budgets is the frame
per second of the game.
I told you all
about the setup, we
went over, the scoring, the
nodes, what the advantages are,
what the simulation
strategy is used.
So you probably want
to see it in action.
So this is always a risky move
trying to get video to play.
AUDIENCE: It's actually
in the back up.
Hit Escape.
PROFESSOR 3: OK.
Got it.
AUDIENCE: And now, I guess, we--
PROFESSOR 3: And
drag it over again?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 3: Running
this full screen.
AUDIENCE: Hit the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3:
[INAUDIBLE] All right.
Here's this MCTS-based
"Mario" playing controller.
You can see he's
actually wrecking, so
doing some serious damage here.
But those lines that you
see, the reason they're
different colors it's not
showing different players,
or anything like that.
It's just using
different colors so you
can see the different
layers of this tree search.
You can see he actually
went backwards there.
And that's because
in a simulation,
when one of the backward
ones landed on an enemy--
and in fact gets you points
from our scoring system versus
if you had just gone forward you
would have gotten some distance
points but not--
also, he is just [INAUDIBLE]
The simulation is quickly being
able to figure out that he
can jump on all his enemies.
So he's just wrecking
all these guys.
Getting lots of points here,
collecting the coin, et cetera.
You get the idea.
It's pretty awesome to watch.
There's that flower
we were talking about.
So now he's actually a
fire-spewing Mario demon.
He's doing some serious
damage with that.
Stepping on missiles.
I didn't even know you
could step on the missiles.
All right.
You could watch
this for a while.
But we'll exit now.
It looks super
promising in this video.
I don't know how
close max stuff.
AUDIENCE: Just click
on back [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 3: There it is.
OK.
The demo looks really cool,
looks really promising.
Let's take a look at the
charts here because we all
want some quantitative stuff.
This is the chart.
The score is on the y-axis.
The bottom is computation
budget, which is something
that you were talking about.
I just want to highlight
to make this a little more
visually appealing here.
All of these things
that I highlighted,
it's labelled as UCT.
That's Upper
Confidence Bound Tree.
Remember, Yo talked about
upper confidence bounds.
That's essentially
what's used in that TTS
for guiding your tree search.
So these are all the methods.
But then UCT multi, which is
this purple square, that's
saying it's using MCTS but it's
doing the multiple simulations.
And you can see this multi
plus care is also in the top.
Both these use the
multi-simulation technique.
And then the plus car is
they added an extra scoring
mechanism for carries.
I believe that's probably
like carrying a shell.
That made it do better.
Then these ones that
aren't highlighted
are using plain Astar, and then
a refined version of Astar.
With increasing time,
the do increase scores,
but they're even worse
than just your UCT
with just random simulation,
no multi-simulations.
We're running low on
time, which is not ideal.
But another thing that I want to
point out is down at the bottom
here, these are the
multi-simulations.
They have the lowest
maximal search depth, which
at first would seem like, what?
I have the lowest search depth
but my score is the most?
But that comes
into play when you
were saying about the trade
off between the simulations
and the amount time it takes.
So because I'm doing
multiple simulations,
I'm taking more
time at each node.
But that's giving me a more
accurate value assessment.
So that let's me choose
my actions more carefully,
or with more information.
And so that's what's able to
give me this better scores.
That's all "Mario."
So we're going to
moving onto AlphaGo.
Are there any questions about
"Mario" before I go to AlphaGo?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's the table
[INAUDIBLE] inference?
PROFESSOR 3: That's
a good question.
I have a feeling it's because
if you're doing best of n,
that's really heavily relying
on your scoring metrics.
Let's say at one step
if I jump and collect
a coin versus if I go
left or right and play,
I'll get more points
if I get that coin.
But maybe, a missile is
going to hit me in the face
if I do that.
It gets rid of
some of the-- it's
forcing you to do certain moves.
AUDIENCE: Is the A*
heuristically using the same
value, the same value
that you're getting
by your simulation?
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah.
I'm not exactly sure what
the Astar heuristic is.
The whole reason that A* is
difficult is because coming up
with heuristics for
these types of games are.
But this is not his
version of Astar.
I believe this is the
Astar that was used by--
I forget the name of the guy--
but he won the AI competition
a couple of years ago.
I'm going to try to
move onto AlphaGo.
Does someone have how
many minutes I have left?
AUDIENCE: Four.
PROFESSOR 3: OK.
We're going to power through.
Here's AlphaGo.
Hopefully, you all
know the rules.
Just in case, I'll just
go through a quick--
19 by 19.
You alternate black
stones and white stones.
You collect enemy stones by
completely surrounding them.
You can surround a single
stone. groups of stones.
And your score is your
territory plus the number
of captive pieces.
So your territory is just the
area that you're surrounding,
and then you just add the
stones you've collected.
The rules aren't
super important.
The main emphasis is there's
very few rules so you
would think it's really simple.
But the complexity of the
game is quite extreme.
At each turn you have about
250 options that you can play.
Each Go game lasts
about 150 turns.
So that gives you a total
of 10 to the 761 games,
approximately.
And to put that in
comparison, here's chess.
You can read those numbers.
Chess is also pretty complex.
But there's 35
options for turns.
Deep Blue.
I think you were talking about
building out the whole tree.
So Deep Blue would build
out the tree for six levels.
And then use this
hard core chess
master inputted heuristic
evaluation that it
used to find the best move.
Except with Go, you
have 250 options,
which already is adding
a lot more complexity.
So that strategy won't
work quite as nicely.
What do we do?
We use a modified
version of MCTS.
Well, it's not what we do.
That's what Google's
DeepMind team did with Go.
They combined neural
networks with MCTS.
Coincidentally, we learned about
neural networks last class.
Probably not a coincidence.
PROFESSOR 3: It's
not a coincidence.
PROFESSOR 3: The we
ordered two policy networks
in the AlphaGo, and
one value network.
And another big
coincidence here,
the two policy
networks are actually
CNN's, which we learned
specifically about last class,
convolutional neural nets.
And the reason for
that is the input
to the policy neural networks
is an image of the game.
And remember, convolutional
neural nets work really
well with images.
What it outputs, though, is
a probability distribution
over the legal moves.
And the idea is, that if a
move has a higher probability
it will be a more promising
move for you to take.
But another key point is
that it's not deterministic.
It's not telling you
to take this move.
It's just assigning a higher
probability to this move.
And this network was generated
by doing supervised learning
on 30 million positions
from human expert games.
Apparently, there's a giant
database of Go expert games.
So that came in handy.
And there were two
different networks trained.
One of them was a slow policy,
the other was a fast policy.
The slow was able to predict an
expert move with 57% accuracy,
which to me was mind blowing.
Using this neural
network, 57% of the time
it could pin where the
expert would place his move.
That took 3,000 microseconds.
Versus the fast policy, which
suffered a bit in the accuracy,
but it's 1,500 times faster.
And we'll see where
they used each
of these different
policies later on.
But it could predict the
expert move with 57% accuracy.
The other Go team was,
that's not our goal.
We don't want to
predict an expert move.
We want to predict
a winning move.
And so to do that, they
took their policy network,
and then they would use
reinforcement learning.
That's where you play the
network against iterations
of itself in order to hone
in a better policy that's
geared towards winning moves.
Then they tested this
against Pachi, which uses--
for the camera, I
have no idea if that's
how you pronounce Pachi.
It might be Patchey.
I'm not sure.
But there's 100,000 MCTS
simulations at each turn.
So this is purely MCTS.
If it were playing just
the AlphaGo policy network,
the policy network
won 85% of the game.
So without any sort of trained
search or anything involved,
it won 85%, which
is pretty great.
And that suggests that
maybe intuition wins
over long reflections in Go.
And interestingly, if you
talk to expert Go players
and you ask them why they did a
certain move, they'll just say,
It felt good, or I
had a hunch in this.
That's indicative there.
Hopefully, I'm not
going overtime.
Sorry.
Those are the two
policy networks.
There's also a value network.
What the value network does
is it takes in a board,
and they'll give you a value,
like how good is this board?
They'll give you a win
probability number.
So 77%, it would say,
77% of the time you
should win from the board.
That's similar to the evaluation
that comes from Deep Blue.
But rather than a Go master
coming in and telling you,
well, if these are
connected in this way,
and down here we have
this certain thing
then here's the score
we should expect,
in chess, they
had chess masters,
like if the knight is here
and the queen is here,
all these specific things.
This was actually learned from
the reinforcement learning that
was happening when the
policy networks were
playing each other.
The value network was
learning about those positions
during that time.
And the predictions get
better towards the end
of the game, which I think
Yo mentioned in his talk.
So how do you combine
all these into MCTS?
The slow policy network,
if you remember,
is slower but should
give us stronger moves.
It is used to guide our
tree search in order
to help us decide which
nodes to expand next.
When we expand that
node to get the value,
the value of the state is
the simulation, like before,
like normal MCTS,
except it's not
a completely random simulation.
We use our fast policy network
to give us a more educated
simulation here.
But we're using a
fast one, obviously,
to save some computation time.
It's giving us probably a more
indicative random simulation
of what's going to
actually happen.
And then we also combine that
with our value network output.
So we run our value network
on this node, as well.
And we add that to
our simulation value
and we propagate it.
Interestingly, the
AlphaGo team tested out
just using the fast
policy simulation value
and scrapping the value network.
And they also just
used the value network
and scrapped the
simulation value.
And those both performed
worse than if it had these.
And another added
interesting point here,
is that these two
factors in our value
have about the same weight.
They were both about
equally important.
I think I'll get
into that later.
But first--
AUDIENCE: Can I just
ask a quick question?
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when you said
the policy network is used,
is that used when you're
navigating to the tree
to get to a leaf,
or is policy network
being used to do the
simulation once you're
at the leaf, or both?
PROFESSOR 3: The slow policy
is done for this part.
Then the fast policy is
used for the simulation.
Because the slow policy does
take 1,500 faster than--
or the slow takes 1,500 times
longer than the fast policy.
You don't want to use
that in your simulations.
That would just
take way too long.
It's basically just
a way of making it
so our simulation isn't
completely random.
It has some educated moves.
Why use policy and
value network synergy?
Why can't we just use
the policy network?
the value network?
If we have the
value network alone,
we'll actually--
here's a side point.
Remember, the value
network learned
from the policy network.
And then also, later
on, the policy network
is improved by our values.
They work hand-in-hand.
But if we had the
value network alone,
when we're deciding
on it the next move,
we're going to have to evaluate
every single move, which
would take forever.
And so, what the
policy network does
is project the best move
with a probably distribution.
And it narrows our search space.
And then, if we had the
policy network alone,
we'd be unable to compare nodes
in different parts of our tree.
The policy network
is able to tell us
a distribution over
which move we should
take from a certain node.
But then, if I ask it if
I'm in a better position
here than in some other
place, it won't know.
That's where the value
network comes in.
It will give us an estimated
number of the value assigned
and open an evaluation
of that node.
And then these
values are later used
to direct our tree
searches based
on updating the policy
once it realizes,
oh, I thought this would be
a good path but the value is
this, so update all that.
Then why do we combine
neural networks with MCTS?
Remember, the
policy network alone
played against Pachi,
which was purely MCTS,
and it did pretty well.
So how does MCTS improve
our policy network?
Remember, MCTS did win
15% of those games.
So already, that makes you
think there's something there
that maybe the policy
network is missing.
Also, the policy network
is just a prediction.
So by using this
tree structure, we're
able to use these Monte Carlo
rollouts to adjust our policy
to move towards nodes that are
actually evaluated to be good.
And then, how do neural
networks improve MCTS?
The point should
probably be clear by now.
We're able to more intelligently
lead our tree exploration.
Our simulations are more
reflective of actual games.
And the value network
and our simulation value
are complementary, which
I've mentioned before.
And just to highlight that,
basically, the value network
is going to give us a
value that is reflective
as if we've played the
slow policy the whole time.
And the simulation is if
we used a faster policy.
So they are complementary.
And I know I'm over time.
So I just wanted to skim
through the stats real quick.
Distributed AlphaGo
won 77% of the games
against regular AlphaGo.
So it's the only thing
that beat regular AlphaGo.
And then distributed AlphaGo
won 100% of the games
against all these.
In a rematch against Pachi,
now that we've added MCTS
to our policy network and
we have our value network,
we slaughtered Pachi 100%.
Then we decided to see how
we fare against humans.
And by we, I mean not
me, I mean Google.
And they won 4 to 1.
And Lee Sedol rating was 3,520.
Now AlphaGo's rating is
estimated to be about 3,586.
So you're like, whoo,
we beat the best dude.
Except we didn't because
there's another dude
who has an even higher
score, apparently, 3,621.
This should be the last part.
Here's this timeline.
Basically, tic-tac-toe,
checkers were conquered in '50.
About 40 years later, we
conquered checkers, chess.
Then we scroll down
to 2015, is when
AlphaGo was able to
beat Fan Hui, who
was a two-dan player, which
is considered lower down
in the tier of professional Go.
But then, Lee Sedol
was a nine-dan player.
And he was able to beat
him literally last month.
PROFESSOR WILLIAMS: So good job.
PROFESSOR 3: We're done.
[APPLAUSE]